So interestingly enough, we can do the trick as before 5!/4!*1!,
which is the number of outcomes at exactly 4 heads and we know that's 5.
Four heads means one tails. There's five ways to place one tails and this one over here.
The question now what's the probability of those?
Well, they have heads four times, (0.8)โด and tail once to (0.2)ยน.
So we do is we multiply the total number of outcomes that have this property
with each one probability, which happens to be the same because we get exactly four times heads
and 1 times tail and multiplying these things together gives us 0.4096.
This over here is indeed 0.4096 and the 5*0.2 cancels the others out,
so that's the result in this specific case.
The cancellation doesn't always happen. It's a rare circumstance.